desperate new measures in some states to
slow the spread of the coronavirus as
you can see
we are heading in the wrong direction
and we are heading there very fast
we had more cases than ever yesterday
with more than 217
thousand new infections the daily death
toll is also headed in the wrong
direction far higher nearly 2 900 people
yesterday alone died of the coronavirus
do the math that's one every 30 seconds
or so adriana diaz is following
nationwide efforts to fight this surge
adriana good morning to you there is a
state home advisory there
in chicago where you are any chance of
that lifting soon i'm guessing not
not at all tony you guessed right in
fact yesterday the mayor said the
advisory remains in place
the risk is just too high here and
nationwide
in the last two weeks 34 states broke
records for new daily coronavirus cases
and that means more patients flooding
into hospitals like here at rush
university medical center
where admissions are up and many
hospitals nationwide say they're being
stretched too thin
if we don't act now our hospital system
will be overwhelmed
california governor gavin newsom
announced plans to impose the strictest
lockdown orders his state has seen
since march after hospitalizations they
are jumped nearly 200 percent
in the last month we are announcing and
introducing a regional stay-at-home
order in the state of california
fundamentally predicated on the need to
stop gathering
with people outside of your household
the order shutters salons and bars and
limits restaurants to take out and
delivery only
in regions of the state where icu's
reach 85 percent capacity
the governor expects most of the state
to hit that threshold
in the next few days help is on the way
in the form of new vaccines
one of which was already approved in the
u.k on the cbs news podcast to the take
out our major garrett asked dr anthony
fauci why the uk approved pfizer's
vaccine
first i love the brits they're great
they're good scientists
but they just took the data from the
fisa company and instead of scrutinizing
it
really really carefully they said okay
let's approve it that's it fauci later
apologized
saying he has confidence in the uk
scientists and regulators
but a vaccine can't come soon enough on
chicago's south side
the crush of new covet patients has
doctors and nurses at roseland community
hospital
wondering how long they can hold on i'm
actually afraid that we're going to get
overrun
nurses like alma abad don't just treat
covet patients
she comforts them in the icu she set up
this ipad to connect 85 year old
florence bolton to her grandkids
it's that kind of separation that makes
losing a loved one to this virus
especially cruel says patrick brent he
lost his 72 year old mother janice
branch to covid
just 10 days ago i couldn't go to
chicago i could be with her i couldn't i
couldn't hold her i couldn't hug her i
couldn't even see her
and the last time i hugged her was you
know a year ago
and she's gone she's gone
we have some more developments on the
pfizer vaccine according to a wall
street journal report the company was
forced to cut its production target for
the end of the year
in half because of issues with
ingredient standards the company said it
revised its targets back in november and
that the u.s is still on track
to receive its 20 million dose allotment
by the end of the year
anthony all right adriana thank you
those separation stories are so
heartbreaking